um moving on to agenda item one
apologies for absence
uh apologies have been received from
councillor joe mcpherson council ian
foster
council christine mason
councillor gary myers councillor james
newport councillor phil shaw and
councillor mike wilkinson
agenda item 2 substitute members
councillor judy gooding is substituting
for councillor gary myers
councillor merrick is substituting for
council foster and council mrs butcher
is substituting for councillor phil shaw
agenda item three non-members attending
we have in attendance council julie
gooding
counsellor cheryl rowe councillor arthur
williams and councillor councillor
daniel f day welcome to you all
all right sorry correction yes no your
councillor julie gooding is actually a
member so that
the
the non-members attending there now
council cheryl rowe council arthur
williams and councillor daniel leftover
oh i'm sorry and council sparing yes
agenda item four minutes of the meeting
held on the 1st of march
2022
are the minutes agreed members
okay thank you those are agreed
agenda item five two declare to receive
declarations of interest
are there any declarations of interest
members
okay there are none thank you
so we move now on to agenda item six
which is the approval of the review
committee's annual report
i'll ask the council's principal
democratic and corporate services
officer sonja worthington to introduce
report sonia
[Music]
thank you chairman
the annual report before you this
evening covers the work of the committee
from the period of june 2021 to the end
of march 2022
it includes a forward from the chairman
as well as listing all members of the
committee during the period covered the
report gives a more detailed overview of
the committee's work
during the past year and sets out the
dates when the committee had actively
discussed those areas of the council's
work streams
before the report is submitted in uh in
july to council
links will be inserted into the document
to the corresponding minutes of review
committee meetings where those
discussions took place it will make it a
bit more of a joined up document for
people they're reading through it
i'd like to take this opportunity to
thank the council's democratic services
officer veronica shushker for all her
hard work on the report
i welcome members comments chairman and
ask that the draft annual report be
approved for a receipt by council at the
next full council meeting
thank you sonya members are there any
questions on the report
cancel a try
so
sorry about that chairman
um chairman i must say that the report i
believe
reads well but a couple of points if i
may
um members may recall that some months
ago we had an external review of the
review committee and the functions of
the rio committee and it was agreed then
uh to change and change its name to the
review and scrutiny committee and i
wonder if that should be reflected in
this report
another point if i may mr chairman um on
the contents page item six
um on page nine it says ripper i think
that that should show its full name
and the acronym should be perhaps shown
in brackets
okay
and they are my only comments thank you
mr chairman thank you councilman
um yeah
the the point about changing the name i
did discuss this with um
the leader and with the chief executive
and what they agreed was that we would
change the name in the next municipal
year so you are right it's just it's not
this this municipal year it will be
changed to well
if subject to council scrutin
approval the
oversight and scrutiny committee
thank you mr chairman um obviously the
role of the review and scrutiny
committee should further should in
future concentrate more on scrutiny as
as well as review yeah thank you and i
think you're right in in the report
which reviewed the review committee i
think the name review everyone accepts
is looking backwards and we shouldn't be
doing that we should be looking forward
so thank you for that and the point
about the ripper is noted and that will
be in the final report
[Music]
in terms of the name change as well
what what what the intention uh will be
uh will be to include um
that recommendation within the report
going into annual council at the
beginning of the next municipal year uh
as as part of the
constitution of committees for 2223.
thank you
so it comes to mrs shaw
on page
7.8
fifth one down it says work in
partnership with other councils and it's
ongoing regular attendance ccc organized
district and climate forum meeting with
ecc to explore opportunities
i think you jump to the next
item sorry
you're wishing our lives away
sorry councillor constable yeah on the
uh ripper if you look at the item six it
says ripper and then it says underneath
it what it stands for that's already
been done on my report
i think what what um
[Music]
you want that in the contents as well
okay
thank you
any further comments members
okay members um i would like to move a
motion that the draft annual report be
approved subject to the
ripper amendment
um
for submission to council do i have a
second
council mr shaw thank you
can those members in favor please show
your hands
okay thank you members that's unanimous
moving now on to item seven which is um
report on carbon neutral by 2030 i'd
like to welcome councillor david sparing
portfolio holder for environment and
place and marcus hoffman the assistant
director for place and environment
who've joined us for this item
marcus can i ask you to introduce a
report please
good evening members um thank you um so
the um the report is a fairly short
report
i i guess it's um
it does on the packet really that it's
just a summary of of the annual uh
progress
of the action plan um probably the
easiest way to explain is to go through
the recommendations on uh 7.4
and then to explain the logic of how
it's been set out
so that um
obviously the report initially goes
through the progress against the carbon
neutral action plan
which you'll find is outlined in
paragraph 3.2
and and really sums up that um
if i'm being brutally honest i guess
we've not made as much progress as i
would have liked
but there are reasons for doing so i
think we've highlighted those in terms
of the fact that a coveted has had
an impact in terms of
resources that could be allocated to
this
you know so it's uh had some uh effects
so you'll see there's about nine actions
there that are amber the ideal should
ought to be green but you know they will
progress and begin to move forward again
um
in terms of looking forward and i said i
think it would be quite a brief report
it was always just on what progress
we've made for the year
a great deal of report is actually about
looking forward so
um we found that uh the carbon neutral
working group
uh was um possibly looking at a wider
terms of reference than perhaps was
originally
envisaged so in many ways
the terms of residents were very narrow
and the action plan itself is quite
narrow so at times we found that
we were often drifting into aspects of
carbon neutrality that were beyond the
scope of the original project and so we
feel that the terms of reference to the
carbon neutral working group ought to be
widened to reflect that moving forward
and that sort of um dovetails very much
went into appendix 3 which is a
sustainability strategy
and which reflects again that wider view
uh district-wide view of addressing
carbon neutral um aims rather than
perhaps just that very narrow view that
we had initially of just addressing
carbon neutrality within the council
and so that sort of covers um
uh
points four and five the recommendation
uh in terms of recommendation three uh
again there is uh some good news once
again looking forward in that we have
been using um brentwood's climate and
sustainability officer to assist with
developing the sustainability strategy
and again we we seek to formalize that
so it's been a trial basis it's worked
very well and so what we're suggesting
is that we actually um progress that i'm
going back to executive from a service
level agreement to say that we'd like to
have approximately about half of that
time of that officer to assist here as
well as at brentwood because
they're quite similar
um ambitions wherever you go across any
district could borrow you know the the
issues of carbon neutrality are almost
the same so um
there's there's some economies there
that can be that can be sort of uh
gained by us joining together on that
and that essentially covers the report
so i'm uh
happy to take any questions thank you
thank you members are there any
questions that
counts the mrs shaw
thank you chairman now won the right
report i do apologize
on 7.8 it's uh the fifth like you've
done it says about regular attendance
where he sees the organized district and
barrow climb and it's online
are you actually managing to get any
meetings with ecc etc and are they
frequent
um
yes through the chair through chair yes
it's it's um there are quarterly
uh and so there has been um four i think
the most recent one was 22nd of march
so i think it's count um i consider
these so i come from the council's name
precisely but i could send you over the
details of those if you wish to
a bit more information on those yes
please because we don't see anything on
essex on them at all well i'll gladly
forward i mean i think they're publicly
inside that we'll check but i'll gladly
fall them on to you thank you very much
thank you
councillor drew
thank you mr chairman um
excuse my ignorance but i wonder if
someone gave me a clue as to how a
carbon footprint is actually calculated
because i don't know
a couple of other points if i may
on page 7.4 paragraphs 8.1 and 8.2
it talks about a resource of 20 000
pounds has been requested
um has that 20 000 pounds already been
agreed
is a question
because i know it's not in the
recommendations
okay
um and also in respect of
um the twenty twenty thousand pounds i'd
like a little bit more expansion as to
exactly how that would be used if that
could be done thank you
thank you so um
can you recall that i i didn't know the
first question i've noticed the second
so so the first question was around the
um
so sorry so
in terms of calculating the file comfort
there is a kind of a set
methodology i won't pretend that i fully
understand uh how it's particular but
it's mainly on um converting units of
energy so whether that's gas electricity
or even oil
and water has some carbon footprint to
that so it's expressed almost in in the
amount of carbon that's used in terms of
either of those um utility consumptions
and it's multiplied up to give you that
that figure so for example for um so
we'd go through basically every electric
every utility bill uh every fuel bill
that we have for the council for the
year and then you you multiply that
against these these this co this carbon
factor and it gives you an overall
tonnage of carbon
thank you thank you
yeah
cancer drive it might answer the second
part of your question um ideally
uh
the this report should have come to
review and scrutiny prior to the
executive
but the leader
was quite insistent that we maintain the
momentum that we've started on this
carbon neutral uh move
and if we hadn't have done it in the
order they went to executive last week
we would have come here this week and we
wouldn't have been able to have
executive till either the end of may or
june um
the executive did agree the twenty
thousand pounds which was not part of
the
uh midterm financial strategy
and they were also made aware that as we
go further down the road there will be
the need for further physical and
financial support to keep the momentum
going which they took on board at the
time but wasn't for a conversation last
week
thank you
thank you
councillor james gooding
yeah
good evening um
page
7.6
item six
um considering the purchase of electric
vehicles it says ongoing have you got
any idea of timeline
for this that's the first question and
the second bit is
really is there any plans any thoughts
infrastructure for charging
these vehicles
thank you um
so um
uh the answer is um
so i'll answer the second question first
the answer is yes because um the
infrastructure is in some ways where the
delay has been in terms of um purchasing
vehicles
i didn't want to purchase vehicles and
discover that we didn't actually have
the infrastructure to charge and rapid
charge
you know so um there's an assumption a
triple charge is fine
but the best one in the world no
reflection on my staff um someone's
going to forget to charge them overnight
at some point and then also you've got
flat vehicles so you need to get a rapid
charge so that um there's a piece of
work that ensured that we had
the power available
and where we're going to charge it it
just took a little bit longer so that
that's been so the answer is yes um
we're going to be putting charging
facilities down at the depot
which is
not accessible to the public we also
anticipate to be putting a charging um
station up hockley woods
which will be available to use by the
public but of course we'll have a
priority for us to charge our vehicles
but it was just ensuring that we had
enough kilowatts
going through the ground as it were to
actually do so um
we are
in our second round so we initially
procured uh a a van as a trial electric
van um the company could not provide us
what we requested at the end of the
procurement unless they could they
couldn't and we've had to re-go out so
we just put that procurement back
together
i would anticipate that we still pretty
much now get a vehicle till probably 14
months time
right but but it's not one now it's um
three vehicles so we are expanding but
the delay has been around
ensuring that um
there's infrastructure
and secondly um
there are the vehicles available
again we use four by fours pickup trucks
and they just aren't the
um super vehicles at this stage so we we
did a real
a good sift you can see i've
been frustrating for me this as well
because i'd like to progress this
further but we have to sort of go
through quite a few sort of um checks
before we got as far as we have right
okay thank you
councillor mrs gadsden
chair good night chair can i just check
with you um i've not been involved with
carbon neutral
working group at all
what i'm interested in finding out is on
page 7.1
3.4 paragraph 3.4
it does say um the production of new
local plan and outcomes are closely
reliant on the progress of these
projects what i'm wondering is is
the council's policy on development on
houses is the materials used green
policies if you like solar energy
water efficient systems etc
and whether there's any sort of liaison
between the carbon group and the
planning be so that they can affect
what we actually build
does that make sense perfectly yes thank
you um so so the short answer is yes
there will be um obviously we're in the
process of reviewing the local plan now
uh and so um i would anticipate um
over the next year you'll start to see a
draft of many of the policies of the
local plan come forward and so as they
come forward um the member working group
we have its work cut out that they will
be asked to
look at those and review those and feed
back into the local plan process
so you know that they were having a
direct influence on on some of those
policies particularly around um building
standards which is where a lot of these
the sort of the materials are i guess
we it's a good opportunity um that we
can't miss so
it's going to be quite a busy time i
suspect for the next year
thank you chairman
can i just add that most of these
developers are fully aware of what's
coming and are on the ball already and
are putting forward their own ideas or
geared up to have to deal with what we
will be asking of them so i
well obviously as marcus has said we're
going to have to make sure we've got all
our paperwork in line i don't think
there'll be any surprises for them in
what they're going to have to address
um cher can i can i just um prove
and cancel sparring
would these apply to small developments
um people one-off houses
small blocks of flats i mean we
obviously we understand that large
developers it's a lot easier for them to
adhere to our policies because of their
financial backing they have
but is this going to be across
the board policy
that insists on a certain level of
um i i don't think we're a position to
say at this stage i mean i mean you know
um certainly um
i think
certainly we're encouraged the working
group and this authority to be ambitious
in its targets but then what you've got
to do is then look at what's um
has been achieved elsewhere so you know
so um officers will
i said um so from a carbon neutral
aspect i will probably say well i want
to be as ambitious as possible but then
we're asked to have a steer from
the planning policy officers to say well
actually look you know this is what's
likely to be approved by an inspector so
there's got to be tempered but we really
can't expect too but it's it's too early
to uh just to ruin a comment on that
loan thank you
sorry makassar are you saying that the
um the government's policies
how firm they are on the green agenda
will directly filter down and affect
what we can insist on
yes i mean i mean yes i mean so so local
policy is always based on national
policy so yes um but the national policy
as as council sparring has alluded to
the the developers are well aware that
there is a change coming if you like and
so i don't give you a surprise it's just
the
the application of that and so you know
um i think some of you are familiar with
brienne i think probably from from our
own um asset development program so
brienne has an accepted standard that is
an easy language to integrate but if we
said we wanted let's say
carbon neutral for every building across
the you know that that's a stand beyond
what is recognized or easy to measure so
you've got to have something that's
tangible and understandable across
across sort of if you like a national
framework
thank you any other questions members
i've got some questions i'm putting
these on behalf of absent members um
do you want me to tell us
yes please yeah okay
the first one is on on page 7.6 of
appendix 1
um and the first
bullet point on the update
says that meter readings are shed sorry
meter readings scheduled and
are incorporated into the annual visit
and this was interrupted due to covert
19. have you got an idea when
those will be updated
yes so um
most of the meter readings are are now
um in if you like we do have most of the
meter readings where where we struggle
of course is some of the approximations
and so um
a lot of the the electric and gas is
easy to get fairly accurate readings but
so the water meter readings if it's not
being read at the time we're now we're
now looking back in time trying to guess
where the water how much usage was it
was at that point in time so
it's
um
wouldn't impact that much on the
footprint the water uses anyway so you
probably get a fairly good idea of what
we have over that year it's just i think
i've alluded to before them as a working
group
it's how useful that would be so i could
confidently predict you that our
carbon footprint for last year was a lot
lower
than the baseline year because most
things were shut
so you know i can do a lot of work for
you come back with that carbon footprint
but the reality is all your goals well
thank you very much you've told us what
we knew already that the leisure centres
were closed and the offices were closed
so
i'm not sure what you'd really achieve
i'd rather take a proper working year so
as we move into that into this year i
said i would suggest that this year
comparing that to the 2018 year will
give us a better direction of travel
whereas the years in between because we
know it's been exceptional circumstances
i just don't think they'll really
provide you with any value
okay thank you
and the next point is on the
um
[Music]
on
page 7.6 and it's the third
row
and we're what it's saying is that we're
awaiting um transfer of assets under the
adp
is there a reason for waiting for for
that before we fix the automated meters
i mean
purely cost you know so it's just a
question of that uh you know i guess
we're expecting the asset development
program to to
move forward uh
fairly soon now so the idea of putting
meters into to buildings that really
won't
contribute to our footprint in the
future might seem non-skull um
i don't think that costs very much so
it's something i am revisiting so we're
getting some information as we as we go
along at the moment so maybe something
we revisit with assets
okay thanks
um
the the next question is relating to
bullet point four
um which was the set in the co2
reduction target
um
and we've got
in page 7.1 of the report
we've got the baseline year of 2018-19
um and that reported
1777 tons of co2
produced across the council activities
could that be used as a baseline
i i i must confess i know you've already
asked me this question and i've puzzled
myself with what i've actually put in
the response um so um the answer is yes
i think we already have a base on the
other so
it's more about the need for a
meaningful non-coverages i think the
first part there can probably be removed
need to establish a baseline first is
actually an accuracy so i apologize for
that i think that could be actually
removed from the report but it leads us
to a meaningful nun code year he's
referring to what i've already said
today you know i can get you some data
but i think it's just not worth
comparing at this time so i apologize
for that okay
um
on page 7.8 the first bullet point about
um
car sharing
it says there's no progress on that but
is that actually the case i know we're
coming out
but is that still the case
it's still the case at the present um i
think that's something we'll start
looking at now that we are out of covey
but i think while we were unsure about
how kirby policy was going to be applied
then i guess having car sharing
uh sort of policies and practices just
just didn't seem to click
yeah okay thank you um
and then um finally on on this on the
same page on page 7.8
bullet points two and three um
can there be a target date set for the
delivery of the of the literacy course
for staff
um
i think i think we said 20 22 it's a bit
broad isn't it but so if i said um
i mean we're looking at this right at
this moment so it's one of the
priorities to get underway
i would
i would say by the end of quarter two
which is i guess october isn't it yeah
yeah so i would be very surprised at
bulk so we don't have that training in
place for senior management
okay
thank you any other
points members
um before we go to the vote
i'd like to read out a statement
that um
the vice chair has asked me to read
unfortunately she can't be here um
so this is verbatim so i'm not going to
do it in her voice
i'm sorry i cannot attend tonight as i'm
covered positive i've asked our chairman
to kindly read this out on my behalf
i would first like to thank marcus
hoffman for all his hard work
marcus as you are also the office
responsible for leading on the waste
contract renewal probably the most
important contract her council has
and overseeing the recent law homes
appeal i hope that members did not give
you too hard a time tonight
i know that given given your hard work
giving you
having continued hard work enough over
this period of time um to push forward
our carbon neutral plans
i would like to say thank you to the
following members who have contributed
to the carbon neutral working group this
municipal year
they are councillor arthur williams
councillor mike wilkinson council mrs
laurene shaw councillor stewart wilson
councillor craig cannell and councillor
mrs julie gooding
carbon neutral working group has not
progressed with the targets as much as i
would have liked but
with thanks to council sparing and
councillor wooden the investment
recommended into this project has been
given and officers confirmed that they
are confident that our targets can be
reached
the latest ipcc report
released only this week urges a now or
never effort to make sure our
environment remains livable
i doubt there is any member that does
not appreciate the need for our council
to expediate our plans
but is only by working together that we
can make this happen
by working together we can contribute
our collective ideas by working together
we can drive this forward to success
as failure is not an option
so that was fun
thank you
so um
members we've got five recommendations
set out at paragraph 11.1
on page 7.4 of the report
which i will move from the chair
do i have a second to please thank you
councillor dre
so that progress be noted on the carbon
neutral action plan
brackets appendix one closed bracket is
that noted members
okay
that the
change in the terms of reference for the
carbon neutral working group
be noted
thank you
be recommended to executive that a
formal service level agreement is drawn
up to secure continued access to the
climate and sustainability officer
can those members in favor please raise
their hands
okay thank you members that is unanimous
um
for that the proposed public
consultation on the draft sustainability
strategy be noted
is that native members
thank you
and that it be noted that a further
paper outlining the proposed finalized
sustainability strategy will be
presented for consideration by the
review by the review committee in the
autumn that noted members
okay thank you members
members move on to item eight on the
agenda which is the key decisions
document which is
obviously getting a lot lighter are
there any questions on the key decision
document
okay there are none thank you
item nine um the work plan members are
there any questions on the workplace
councilor dre
um thank you madam mr mr chairman sorry
one fluid
one thing that i'd like to see included
in there is the um
the flood forum a review of the criteria
stroke terms of reference for the flood
rule forum if that can be included
yep
our members happy for that to be added
okay thank you if you can
put that into the next municipal year
thank you
before i close the meeting um i just
like to say a few words
um i'd like to thank all members of the
committee and the officers for their
support during this what i've always
called a transition year where we've
been making big changes
um and i'm really conscious that in
moving to the new ways of working that
the amount of time required by members
of this committee has probably doubled
it's gone up a lot more than than before
and i believe it's
bearing fruit now where we have in the
pre-meetings in effect we're having two
meetings but it is bearing fruit because
i think a number of things
for example tonight
council james gooding was able to pick
up
some of the questions that an absent
member
was going to ask so i think it gives us
that that resilience
um it's not within my gift to organize
the committee for the next municipal
year
and it would be very presumptuous of me
to think that that would be so but i
would like to hope that to those of you
that have been members of the committee
that if you've enjoyed it you would like
to continue on it and help
bring on other members as well
um
one thing that i've asked for i've asked
officers to consider early training for
the future committee in the next
municipal year because i think we
and it might not be me but whoever is
here needs to hit the ground running i
think one of the lessons that we learned
is having training early on before we
got started was really really useful
um and finally i would like to wish
all those members who are standing for
re-election uh good luck and uh
hopefully they'll see you on the other
side so members i've now formally closed
the meeting at uh
2005. thank you members chair
thank you
chair can i make a statement please just
quickly just like to say you've been an
excellent chair it's been a pleasure
working with you thank you thank you
it's been a pleasure working with you it
makes it easy if you've got a good group
of people
leading a team is easy
so thank you all very much thank you
he's been really good
thank you